das ist wirklich erschreckend ich hatte
es hier ja schon mal beschrieben in
meiner kindheit wenn man da im sommer
mit dem auto fuhr war es voller toter
insekten es war wirklich übersät heute
ist das nicht mehr der fall in den
letzten rund 30 jahren haben wir drei
viertel der insekten vernichtet das ist
eine absolute katastrophe
denn betroffen sind auch die bienen die
für die menschheit so wichtig sind aber
wir können etwas tun kriegs um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinieren die wissenschaft videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
wissenschaftler von der harvard
university für gesundheitswesen in
boston haben die folgen des
bienensterbens untersucht würden die
bienen aussterben werden weltweit 23
prozent weniger früchte 16 weniger
gemüse und 22 prozent weniger nüsse und
getreide geerntet eine absolute
katastrophe
die folgen wären vitamin a und b mangel
71 millionen menschen wären so
zusätzlich weltweit von vitamin a mangel
betroffen 2,2 milliarden sind bereits
heute schon betroffen
dort würde der mangels schlimmer werden
bei 1,23 milliarden menschen würde sich
der vitamin d-mangel verschaffen und 173
millionen wären zusätzlich davon
betroffen die wissenschaftler um semmel
meyer rechnen mit 1,42 millionen toten
jährlich durch das aussterben der bienen
und 700.000 wenn sich die bienenvölker
weltweit halbieren und wenn wir nicht
endlich gegen das damit verbundene
insekten sterben vorgehen hat es noch
viel mehr konsequenz in der zeit wurde
das auf bemerkenswerte weise auf den
punkt gebracht wenn wir unserem
ökosystem drei viertel des fundamentes
wegschlagen
ist das ein massiver eingriff in die
natur ordnung mit anderen worten das
kann unser ende bedeuten also zu einem
massensterben führen inklusive
menschheit riesenproblem viele insekten
sind zudem mit bestimmten pflanzen eine
art symbiose eingegangen sie leben
voneinander stirbt das insekt aus wird
das auch die pflanze treffen es wird
eine schreckliche kettenreaktion
eintreten und sie hat ja schon begonnen
auch die vögel dezimieren sich in
deutschland durch das insekten sterben
werden auch darüber berichtet es sind 57
prozent weniger tiere bei den
brautpaaren in europa fast zwei drittel
und bestimmte vogelarten
das besonders hat es gibt 80 prozent
weniger kiebitze die rebhühner sind vom
aussterben bedroht hier liegt der
rückgang sogar bei 84 prozent sind
weiter wachtel star turteltaube
gartenrotschwanz braunkehlchen und so
weiter und so fort inklusive der
vorwarnliste für vom aussterben bedrohte
brutvögel sind es 87 prozent der arten
die betroffenen sind fast 90
wir müssen unbedingt handeln die
menschheit muss handeln
die gründe sind dabei sogar ziemlich
simpel zitat tenside spielen mit
sicherheit eine ganz große rolle wir
können davon ausgehen dass es besonders
bei kleinen naturschutzgebieten durch
verfassung über die luft zu einer
kontamination der fläche kommt das sagt
der jan christian abel vom lehrstuhl für
terrestrische ökologie der tu münchen
dem zdf magazin frontal 21
wer also etwas gegen das bienen und
insekten sterben tun will und das damit
verbundene vogelsterben sollte also mehr
produkte vom bio bauern kaufen die keine
gifte einsetzen die für die insekten
gefährlich sind oder auch apfelsaft von
streuobstwiesen
das ist schon ein erster schritt in
bayern werden jetzt nägel mit köpfen
gemacht je soll per volksbegehren der
schutz von bienen und insekten deutlich
verbessert werden
und ich kann nur jeden bitten das
volksbegehren dort zu unterstützen wie
hier von unserer produktionsfirma jona
lakers sind dabei geht auf die seite von
bienen rap.de dafür einfach hier
draufklicken und die anleitung befolgen
damit kann schon mal in bayern richtig
was bewegt werden macht also mit und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran